[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
kids
what's going on guys we're here finally
as you can see it's downloaded we're
gonna get to that
be patient i'm gonna see if my my audio
is decent give me a second
we are here finally as you can see all
right all right so it looks like
it looks like the realm can hear me man
i you know
we're going we're going we're going to
play this we're going to play this i
ain't going to enjoy it
but we'll play i don't know maybe i'll
enjoy it maybe it's been long enough
to where i'll feel comfortable playing
skyward sword
and the fact that we got breath of the
wild maybe this is
more of a zelda type of game than breath
of the wild was so maybe i'll be a
little bit more
open to this game
uh so we'll go ahead and
start it up man
let's hope man i have all the confidence
in the world
that they're gonna get me with here man
all the confidence
the unraveler ela7 i don't know what
that means man i have no idea what that
means
you have to be a little more specific
is it coming out the tv too
it is why is it coming out the tv
what's going on here
i got to fix it
okay hold up gotta turn that monitoring
off
there we go only one one
sound surveil man played it
right now while listening appreciate it
man appreciate it we're going to get
into it
oh saludin i appreciate it they burnt
forest to the ashes
give me a second why i look at this
cutscene man i gotta
gotta pay attention i don't remember
nothing about this game
i remember little things about this game
but not anything of
real captivating realness i don't
remember
they did all this in their lust to take
the ultimate power
protected by her grace the goddess
she looked like some kind of harp i'm
assuming that's the master sword
like a gorgon there the power she would
without stand i couldn't read all of it
handed down by the gods of oh this power
gave its
holder the means couldn't read it all
such a ultimate power that the old ones
placed in the care of the goddess
i'm assuming this is the triforce to
prevent the great power from falling
into the hands of the evil swarming the
lands
so that protecting the triforce man
might not be the triforce i think the
triforce was made after this game
can't remember it since the skyrocker
beyond the reaches of the demonic hordes
beyond even the clouds now do remember
that's where you are
within the humans say the goddess joined
forces with the land oils and fought the
evil forces selling them away
we selling stuff away man at least
peace was restored to the surface can't
wait to play a proper 3d
zelda game again it's been 10 years
i will give this game one thing this
game's more of a proper zelda than
breath of the wild was this is the tell
that you humans have told for many
generations
there are other legends long away from
the memory that they are intertwined
with this tale
now a new legend is born to the great
story stands
a legend that will be forged by your own
hand
one of my favorite uh legend of zelda
games hopefully the quality of life
changes is more enjoyable
we'll keep this in mind man i'm a
i'm really trying to put a lot of time
into this
the legend of zelda skyward sword so
let's set the controller down let's talk
about how
well the intro at least is like the
shimmering off the zelda
icon this gives me like kind of like
a legend of zelda ocarina of time
filling because uh because
and the title screen for that if i
remember correctly it was link
on a horse going through high rules uh
uh
through the the little the little area
in front of
the hyrule castle
uh we're not listening that again it's
not happening we're gonna go into this
so we got the classic title screen man
got the
classic title screen i'm kind of like
excited a little bit to play this
because
i can't remember a whole lot about it
let's talk about the stuff i remember
i remember the weirdo that you fight in
some cavern i remember the big black
thing
so there is things i remember about this
but man what did the original
skyward sword come out let's check that
out real quick
zelda skyward steroid what did the
original one come out let's look
it came out in 2011
that was 10 years ago i don't remember
nothing about it because i played it
the day it came out i like the format
better than breath of the wild
to be honest with you i've i've told a
lot of people that
i have a huge issue of how breath of the
wild was done
i'm not gonna lie
[Music]
what should i name us man what should i
name us should we go with the
conventional
link should we go with that or should we
make it something unique
because i mean what should i name this
after one of the lords what should i do
i'm curious man i definitely agree with
you capo i
hate the shrines the strides have always
been
like i always felt like the shrines in
legend of zelda
breath of the wild was more of like
filler than anything it's like
they didn't have the actual stuff that
they wanted to to make it
the game that they wanted to uh as far
as temples
it was so i felt like in terms of
something like this that
you know skyward sword is a more
traditional game than this
so let's see someone said kink someone
said uh
stink someone said link zelda
man you guys are
talking some crazy stuff man hold up so
hold up hold up
stink link
someone says zelda let's put that in
there
lord amiibo that's all we can fit
all right so you guys tell me i give it
give it two minutes before we start man
two whole minutes tell me what you guys
feel like it should be i'm curious i
will go whatever you guys go
clearly we're not going with nothing
crazy all right we're not gonna
put some disrespectful stuff on the
screen and it's all jokes man it's all
jokes
looks like stink is winning we have a
winning stink going on right now so it's
a break but unfortunately it's too late
man
unfortunately it's too late
seven votes it looks like uh stink is
still
winning give me a second let me go to my
profile vote for what
what i want it to be because obviously
it's
i get i get a vote in the state too you
guys i i'm playing i get a vote too
you guys can't silence me
looks like link is winning i will give
it a minute
so when it hits 501 we're going whatever
is the top
results because that's how we do things
man we do things here as a democracy
well actually that would be a democracy
would your vote yeah that's a democracy
lord amoeba won't fit i don't have an
amiibo
i believe in playing the game how it was
supposed to be playing
i don't believe in cheat codes i'm
looking at you king
can't twist my neck anymore like that
man we're gonna move on
looks like lord amibo is winning this
man
that's kind of weird i wonder if it
doesn't look like it will
fit but i think amiibo will i think we
can definitely fit amiibo
in there we just can't fit lord part
[Music]
l amiibo help me help me
it's going to sound crazy in some of the
scenarios
that's in this game i keep pushing the
wrong
button
[Music]
little man that's that's eight
we can fit little man we could fit
little man if we wanted to
let's see hold up let's see if little
man fits it's eight so
it definitely would fit if we wanted it
oh
doesn't fit
looks like it looks like lord amiibo
about to win this man hold up
l
oh my god i need to stop doing that
[Music]
little green dork we we don't we ain't
doing that man we ain't doing that hold
up hold up
let me why is this one
okay l
a
m i
b o lord amoeba fits perfectly well l
amiibo we can't fit lord amiibo
lord link i don't know man i really like
that but i
i i already said i'd give you guys it
man i can't
i can't go back and change things i
already agreed
to let the chat pick his name and i
can't go back on that
that's not how i roll man that's not how
i wrote
so it looks like we're gonna go with
lord amiibo well l amiibo
because you guys won man you guys won
guys making me look real suspect making
me plays el amibo
so we starting with the the ground
cracking okay
that's the thing i remember that black
thing i remember fighting that some
in some cave man that's all i remember
that is not me talking that is most
likely lord cognito there
so everyone say hi to lord cognito he's
in the chat
acting a full he probably picked lord
amivo
be uh being who he is you know he could
have picked link and made this
seem legit but we got to play lord
amiibo
i can't believe i'm playing this whole
game is my character name
el amibo
i remember the birds i remember like you
get a bird of some sort somehow
oh it's king it's king what's up stew
man what's up stew
[Music]
look at the just jumping off man they
got a lot of faith in these birds they
got a lot of faith in these birds
a lot of faith in these birds i'm too
big to be
on those birds i jump on those birds
that bird is going down i'm going to the
ground
i'm a dead person man i can't can't rely
on a bird to
to to make 250 pounds fly
it ain't happening
[Music]
there's that that that uh
harp all right so here we are
unless it's a plane right uh yeah unless
it's a play
yeah there's the thing i remember
fighting
[Music]
i don't remember what he's about though
we'll have to get to that later
rise el amibo oh my god i can't believe
i'm about to say the whole game
the time has come for you to awake
you are failed to have a hand in great
destiny
and it will soon find you the time has
come for you to awake
l amiibo
yo you guys are i hate you guys
i gotta play this game as el amigo
it's a big bird
it's a big bird man i have fallen out of
bed
so i'm a klutz too
and then somehow nothing else fell off
of the shelves or anything like that
i kind of felt like i i made a huge loud
noise when i fell too
oh it's a delivery bird okay
so birds are delivering mail
it's not un un it's not unheard of that
you know
people used to have like the crows
deliver mail and stuff in like game of
thrones so i get that
hey sleepyhead i know how much you like
to sleep in so i'm guessing this letter
will be your alarm clock this morning
did i guess right you did you did gross
right i don't know who this is
rise and shine elementa el amibo today's
the wing ceremony
you promised to meet before it starts
remember you better not keep me waiting
i have no clue who this is
zelda okay so zelda we about to go meet
hold up i gotta get used to the i
remember
like okay
let's open the doors it's like the right
button you push to move over
okay yeah okay hold left
move camera why can't i just move the
camera without the holding left part
humble over here struggling he's
struggling
[Music]
see i i i can hold this this is where
i'm at
let's put it down though
[Music]
good morning people i can't get over
that element will taste a big wean
ceremony right
i wanted to fly but i didn't make the
cut so i'm stuck back here
at the academy plus i've got to move
these barrels to keep the kitchen
i was hoping to at least be able to
cheer you on el amibo but
get i guess that's the way it goes go
out there
and wow then buddy can i move the barrel
i can help you fam hold up hold let me
see if i can
pick these up and move this barrel
pick it up
hold up let's pick this up
i won't let me pick up the barrel let's
put them back though let's
oh hold up
let's put them back we can't we can't be
rude
this isn't exactly how they was but this
is good this would be fine
he gets tired really fast
what's this dude one morning el amibo oh
my god
man i can't get over that why did i let
you guys pick my name
so today's the wing ceremony are you
ready i'm saying everyone else is
practicing at the plaza
but you seem pretty relaxed about the
whole thing of course that crimson
loaf wing of yours is something special
i feel pretty confident riding him too
my bird won the last ceremony but even i
didn't think he could beat that red tear
of yours
oh because you swing the sword with the
right stick
oh okay okay okay you're welcome at it
happy uh
journeys i appreciate it man of course a
bird's true speed as a race always comes
down to the
the skill of the rider i'm something of
a bird researcher
around here so you know if you find
yourself in the need of a bird expert
come
see pippets or you know as i can't
pronounce
nothing we're gonna move past that
though
all right so
what's going on over here
[Music]
look at this zimnis looking dude from
kingdom hearts tell me this dude don't
look like zimnis from kingdom hearts
[Music]
is kingdom hearts wannabe dude you in
the wrong game man
you're in the wrong game
can i like change hold up
motion controls off
we don't need these amiibos we play
games
we we we play games to play games king
we don't need those amiibos
hold up
there we go that's better
[Music]
oh it's locked there's doors locked here
man that's kind of messed up
oh what's up raiden
looks like some good food man
this dude over here won't shut up
there's a restroom
this is a pretty basic restroom
oh i can sit on the restroom
oh and it flushes gotta automatic flush
they in the future
[Music]
got bad some of these textures look man
they look pretty bad i'm not gonna lie
skyloft we have made it
to skyloft well i guess we didn't make
it to anything we was always at skyloft
but we're
close man we're close
what is this a bird statue oh so this is
how you save
[Music]
what's up cerberus paul hey lord amiibo
up here
while they all have the same facial
expressions
good morning to you lord amiibo today's
finally the day of the long awaited wing
ceremony
are you feeling ready oh i just
remembered there's something i'd like to
ask you about target me
and we can grab a quick chat
so i gotta target them
excellent always remember you can target
someone to talk to them easily
and even when there isn't anything to
target it's convenient in a way to
quickly
face you the view direction but it's a
little silly to carry a conversation
from the distance why don't you come up
to join me
why didn't you say come up to join me
from the start oh it's
it's like they they did something so you
would have to learn how to target
you should be able to climb up if you
dash to the top of that wooden box
[Music]
try climbing up here okay okay
oh here we go
so what are you up to rushing to get the
last minute bird writing practice
in the morning l amiibo amiibo
i'm gonna laugh the whole game oh
you have someone to meet oh zelda's
waiting for you is she perfect timing
then
you'll see zelda's uh father's
headmaster as a bet name
mia and you as she's was randolph
look look over there don't you see
her the headmaster's so worried praying
for the ceremony i thought that maybe i
should feed her but the ceremony's about
to start
and i just put some fresh set of clothes
and well you see will you help me out
and go retrieve mia for me
i guess we'll do it i guess
i feel like we're being forced to go do
something
this should be able to climb in
somewhere over there if you hang off the
ledge you could climb into the roof
from the other side don't have to tell
me how to climb
ain't nobody asked you for that
information
[Music]
telling me how to climb
[Music]
i don't like not knowing who's in that
iron lords podcast account
this might be the goat if it's the goat
then why don't you play
can i climb to this one hold up
maybe i should have read it i don't know
we we don't need
we don't need help though man we don't
need help
we don't need help we can we can learn
this by ourselves man
[Music]
we got this we got this
[Music]
i'm five ford i can't and i still can't
climb
oh the oh my god go go go go
let's let that revive a little bit man
[Music]
climbing
[Music]
can i push this yep
oh i did it
where'd it go
is it flying back up
it's falling back up i didn't think
they'd let me do that i ain't gonna lie
i didn't think they'd let me do that
if it could fly this whole time why is
it up here
[Music]
take this creepy thing nice work you
brought her back in safe and sound
sorry for the troubling with you this i
know you're busy ella amiibo i suppose
i should feed mia now that's probably a
good thing
tell that master that we found his petty
should be up by the statue of the
goddess
i believe that is there with him oh so
zelda is there oh he gave me
he gave me twenty dollars that was the
easiest twenty dollars i'll probably
make this whole game
astanama fruit
stan
uh here we go cut scene
cut scene guys
i feel like i can make that just a
little tad smaller
just a tad small
youth guided by
let me see what it looks like now
yeah that's fine servant of the goddess
united earth and sky beyond light to the
land
[Music]
i found lane on the ground yeah it it
makes sense man you definitely want to
eat anything lying on the ground
especially mushrooms
i'm glad to see my loft wing got you out
of bed
i was pretty sure you'd sleep in and
forget to meet me this morning
but look at this instrument and look at
this outfit their mind to use today in
the ceremony
since i'll be playing the role of the
goddess
[Music]
aren't they beautiful especially the
instrument they tell me it's just like
the one the goddess
was said to have in the legends
[Music]
um aren't they beautiful oh okay i
already read that
so uh it sounds gorgeous too i i asked
father about it he says it's called a
harp
so at least we know what a harp is
and look at these clothes i made this
right myself and we get used to it to
the
ceremony today because the harp in this
alpha i'm going to make
great goddess today i got you up this
early because i wanted to
to be the first to see me like this el
amigo
oh my god man oh i i forgot about the
asking questions
nah that ain't it that ain't that zelda
[Music]
you have to go back to the drawing board
you're so ain't it i can't i can't be
seen with you i think your dad's coming
and i i kind of want to hide i don't
even want to be seen with you
[Music]
yep it's his father oh everyone people
you're here too outstanding
it's encouraging to see you so er up so
early
man this let's talk about how
lazy's link is in this game
everyone in this game says i'm over
sleeping
what have i ever done anything in my
life they always
give the the triforce of courage or in
this case he doesn't have it yet
they always give it to the most lazy
person in the village
remember an awkward time what was he
doing when the fairy came to you
you were sleeping i feel like there's
issues with that man
might be intentional
if you win today's ceremony race you'll
get to participate in the post original
with zelda so give it your best out
there
[Music]
yes about that father i don't know if
he can do it recently uh el people
hasn't been practicing much out for the
ceremony
see i'm not practicing not practicing at
all for the ceremony
this is like the olympics to them and
i'm just i'm just
taking life on easy mode man
[Music]
i don't know what he's thinking he's
going to have to be perfect control of
the bird to win today
nah i'm sorry this is me we talking
about zelda
i ain't losing
i don't lose zelda you're just gonna
have to get over that
we doing that original together and
that's just how it is
though you may have a point today when
some of the tests uh the skills of the
writer as well as his bond to his birth
victory will not come easily
he's wrong too him and his
tekken looking ass i'm going to win this
that's all that there is to it and you
pointed out i haven't seen him
practicing as hard as some of the other
students but you know him since he
uh were very little you should know
better than to freak about him
see i like that this dude's got faith in
me zelda don't the other think i'm about
to lose like a scrub
i'm about to win
as you know each of us in skyloft is
but one half of a pair we are only made
by our
loft wings the guardian birds the
goddess bestows upon each of us
as a symbol of her divine protection
when we are young every one of us meets
our loft wing under the great statue of
goddess
it's quite a big moment i'm sure you
will recall
[Music]
what's up jared mcmahon how you guys
doing but the first meeting
between el amibo and his long wing
extraordinaire the bird that came to him
was a crimson loft wing i guess that's
that's it is a rare breed so we sure for
some time that it's been vanished from
the line
zelda zelda's a hater zelda is a hater
man zelda be hating
all me this entire game so far yes and
the boy and his birds seem to share a
profound connection from the moment they
met
do you recall when ella moving on there
first met what a sight
the little boy just hopped on that bird
and gracefully flew away without even a
moment of instruction
they were meant for each other and by
judging how jealous you were that day
i'd say the friendship he shared with
his bird didn't go
unnoticed by you my dear see look the
dad believes in me
but zelda is a hater we got to get zelda
out of here
but who can blame you i'm sure you
weren't the only
envious of the powerful bond shared by
el amigo and his bird
see that kind of foreshadows that
there's another hating dude
in this on this place somewhere that's
going to come at me
anyone in the sharing that something
special is bonnie catch something nasty
look sooner or later
[Music]
this contest is nothing to laugh at
father the seminar is part of the final
test
for those who became uh become knights
of skarloft
if eleanor doesn't fly fast during
uh enough during the race
what if eleanor messes up his big
chances but if he's not allowed
to become a knight once again already
she hating on me man
she hate knobbing
calm down my dear it will be fine
honestly
it's almost as though you become a
completely different person
when you worry about ella amiibo
listen el amivo you better fly your
hearts off today at the very least you
need to squeeze in a little practice
time before the race and this is where
they teach me how to fly a bird before i
do this big ass test
flying a bird
here we go go on now jump off the edge
she's trying to kill us i think that's
what's going on here
you can't sense your bird out there oh i
get it you're trying to weasel out of
having practice
nice try but you're not fooling me she
gonna push me off watch yep
she's gonna push me off she's like she's
a psycho man
she's trying to kill me
where's the bird
yeah i just got killed i just got killed
hang in there amigo my bird just
straight it was like
i'm out you dead appreciate uh yeah i
got a new haircut
look at that she she threw me off and my
bird was like finally
this is the opportunity i've been
waiting for to get rid of this dude
i'm sorry friend i didn't mean to push
you sorry you didn't sprain your wing
did you
this is a very odd element should have
possibly happened to your loft wing
for a birth to ignore the call of its
master is unheard of
and you still can't sense your bird
nearby ella out
ll amigo this is quite a problem
especially considering the wing ceremony
is about to start
we'll see now look i'm about to lose
because my bird's gone
and the only reason my bird ain't
showing up is because of zelda's hating
ass i'm convinced
she ain't she done went and found my
bird and she's not trying to hear me in
this competition
ellie when you said you couldn't sense
your loft when what i should
have believed you i'm sorry
i need to tend to my loft wing so i'll
catch up with you later
you better go off and see if you can
find where your bird has gone
my bird's gonna be like a dungeon man i
can't remember where the bird goes to
i remember zelda getting captured i do
remember that
how did you get to be so late if i
recall this year instructor i was
presenting over the ceremony
elmo's should go explain the situation
see if he's willing to delay the race a
little while so you can find your bird
let's go talk to this dude so he can
tell me i can't do nothing
[Music]
she got a point there
you make an excellent point my dear very
well i explained the situation to him
myself oh we will run along and tell
to come see me in my quarters and i like
how they did that
like that branch thing they wanted to
show you the uh
the the cave that you're ironically most
likely about to go into
so we're gonna we're going to uh ignore
that cave
yeah see that cave there i love how they
did the the
the pan back to let you see that cave
acting like you ain't going to that cave
can i go to that cave now why wait
oh probably it's probably where i'm
going
if i remember correctly
look at this payton bird you didn't even
do a lot bird
you just picked me up and flew her and
me
up here it wasn't even that much
as i could see why she's not in the race
now i could see that
she's not in the race because i don't
think she'll do very well
just be real with you i don't think she
would do very well
oh stan i'm a fruit
my fruit
no what's wrong el amivo you're looking
a little pale what
your low foot is missing how strange and
troubling do you think you can find him
you're going to start looking for him
how will you make it back in time to fly
in the ceremony it looks like your
participation
and uh sarah mckeen's on the feather or
not you can find that bird on time
on feather what is that like if i get a
feather what just make my bird spawn out
of nowhere
you can find that bird on time excuse me
i see so the headmaster has summoned me
all right then i'll go speak with him
immediately
i still owe you for helping me out early
so don't worry about the ceremony for
now just focus on finding your looming
all right so
we're gonna go find my uh my bird
my bird is missing
[Music]
wow that was a crazy hit
he's gonna do it again too watch come on
come on you ain't gonna do it again
that's lame i expected that
kid to do that again i'm not gonna lie
yum yum yum yum
oh
we can jump off all these little
platforms one by one
[Music]
oh it looks like the entrance is blocked
off
water 4k be over the blood sucking
monsters no kids allowed
probably gotta get i think you get the
weapon before you can go in there i
don't remember
there looks like there needs a
diamond head eye
maybe that's how you open it up
i i saw a lot of people streaming it so
i
i don't know we'll see i saw a lot of
people streaming it
[Music]
i ain't trying to talk oh they're gonna
make me talk to them
[Music]
such a beautiful day but we're too busy
to enjoy it some things never change
it's not the truth the only thing my
lunchtime son
all i could all i do is laundry laundry
it never ends
i hear you and i'm terrible at washing
clothes i wish i could get someone to do
it for me
oh so they're gonna block the bridge
with laundry
that's that's crazy
nintendo kind of found a different
excuse for me not to go over there
just some some women with laundry that's
kind of crazy if you think about it
what is this and a door ironically being
made where i can't get into
it's like the game's pushing me in one
direction
[Music]
i don't know neither ocarina of time or
twilight princess
[Music]
uh what does this chick have to say
pardon me amiibo have you seen carilla
definitely butchered that definitely
butchered that
have you she's always running out with
the war without a word to anyone i don't
know what i'm going to do
with her i guess she'll never learn
unless she runs into trouble one day
all right so i assume i'm gonna save
that chick it's gonna be something
making me save safer
let's go in this door
oh so all of these places have this
what do you want ever heard of the
banging your knuckles against the door
it's called
knocking bargain to sell on his house is
what most people call brew anyway you're
lucky i'm home
i'm used over those working for my saw
and we're close to the wing ceremony
most of the day i can think about is how
bored i am but now i'm
not works i'm not even bored my life is
pretty sad
man someone needs to get this chick on
some meds she kind of
she kind of bummed me out right now
all right so it's not this one it's not
this one up here
let's go over here
[Music]
[Music]
a small wallet why do you always have a
small
wallet why can't we just have normal
sized wallets
i'm assuming i need my bird to get over
there
that's the save point
this is a new soundtrack it's not an old
one
i really like the new soundtracks
they showed me that cave for a reason
i think i gotta go to that cave
you got a heart decides life-game
reasons to run your hearts
i do got an absurd amount of hearts to
be at the beginning of a zelda game
let's go over here
so i went over there they're not talking
to me
i've not done any combat yet right now
i'm trying to find
my my bird
[Music]
i don't remember where to go
looks like there's something under there
too can you can you swim link
can you swim swim link
can you dive link can you do anything
link
i guess not link is is useless like
[Music]
normal
what is this
oh oh we found something
you're a grocer that was such a pain
with all the scratching and pecking
of course it was you got a big crimson
loafton like that was gonna be
go down without a fight but we got him
and i don't care how tough those birds
are supposed to be he's not getting out
of the pin at any time soon boys
[Applause]
[Music]
think about easy i just could have died
because they they they snatched my bird
[Music]
how long you've been standing there
what's your problem anyway i get it
you're here to talk about the today's
race
i can't see it in those dopey eyes of
yours
they're pleading mr goose can please
fight in your heart to let
you uh me win today please you're just
desperate to win so you can get time
below with zelda
up at the statue of the goddess at the
end of the ceremony
i don't know man zelda was hating on me
pretty hardcore there go
grooster goose however you want me to
pronounce this red hair dude's name
[Music]
ooze yeah i'm not even reading
that that's weird i don't want to see
your eyes like that
come to think of how come i don't see
your bird where is that
red feathers i can't imagine what's
happened to him do you think his tiny
brain got confused
by the clouds and got lost
i'm a compliment on his his nice little
red hair man that's what i'ma do
[Music]
layoff
[Music]
friends you've been friends since
big deal if it doesn't change the fact
that you've been floating you've been
flowed through life with your head in
the clouds
this dude really don't like me
[Music]
would you wake up straighten up and grow
a backbone already
dope's like you're dragging out honored
academy through the mud
oh oh zelda here to save me
[Music]
zelda hey it's uh this dude's so scared
is that it's unfair
don't you even try goose you're picking
on a little b uh
l amiibo again
he's a student at the academy like all
of us
why do you insist on bullying him around
so much
yeah i suppose
you're supposed supposed what's
i suppose you are
what is he doing forget it i wasn't
supposing anything okay
look at that that the way that dude look
later we'll hope you find your bird or
else you're gonna have to sit out
today's race
that could be a major setback to towards
knighthood so find the bird or get real
used to the taste of failure
it's your special flavor
[Music]
let's take his bird i feel like that's
fair
being expected those blockheads had
something to do with your loss when
disappearance
alamou those guys aren't going to help
us find your birds we're better off
start searching
we're going to search that cave i'll fly
around let's go off to see if i can spot
any trace of your murder
father said he's going to instructions
delaying ordering the
start of the fairness so don't worry
we'll find your bird in time
how how much of an idiot do you think he
feels that he went through all this
trouble to steal your bird
and we still gonna be in this race we
still gonna be in this race
ain't nothing stopping me from getting
that w
[Music]
nothing stopping me from getting that w
oh so now there's someone over here
see what he wants look at this thing who
knows how long the statue has been here
it only has one opportunity you probably
know this but you can press
up to look around now i know it
can you see her flying around hold up
can you see her flying around i see a
bunch of people flying around i don't
know if it's her though
it might be just regular birds too not
necessarily me as zelda flying around
that attention to detail would have came
in handy
what's up 108
some butterflies that dude's an idiot
what is this it's like a windmill of
some form
see what's at the top of this
[Music]
look how he climbs up this
[Music]
it's a long it's a long ladder not
really feeling this ladder not gonna lie
to you guys
you're done with life life is over
watch your step there you can't always
depend on knights like me to swoop in
and save you
oh man i thought it was over i thought i
was about to just be able to end the
stream man
these people up here delaying this
the stream in could have finished the
whole game
link would have just died there we
wouldn't have to do no more of this game
el amibo gonna save just to be on the
safe side
what's going on over here
nothing
maybe they'll move now hold up
but yeah they're not moving these these
women are stopping me from
from getting my greatest potential man
well he's there so clearly
they want me to do something
with this
yep there we go here we go
my birds in there
oh hold up wait wait wait
my birds in there man how'd they even
catch my bird
look at this thing you know how long
it's been there okay okay
how do i get in there
i don't remember anything about this
part
maybe
all right so i can do that let's look at
this side
same thing
[Music]
all right so that's that's pointless
so i guess maybe i gotta go back and
find zelda and tell her that my bird's
in this cave
the birds in the cave
where's zelda
where is zelda
[Music]
zelda i found my
bird
[Music]
i think this was locked last time i came
here
no it's the chick that needs to be on
anti-depressions
so that's not where i go
uh let's go back in this building here
maybe some dialogue opened up because of
the zelda dialogue
have you seen she's always running out
without a ward in i don't know what i'm
going to do with her
all right so she's probably talking
about the idiot that keeps
running into the tree so that's where i
would guess who she's referring to
[Music]
wish i knew where to go
get the almighty king to explain to me
where to go
he he knows all
king knows all
oh this dude looks like he knows his way
around getting in
in caves doing ceremony theme today
here in the scarlet spinner right along
and it separates the kids from the
adults
you guys become a knight good tech needs
to even more
fly you are useless why is there so many
oh i mean there's not a lot of beds in
here look at the detail on this stuff
it's
it's kind of pathetic let's be real here
it's kind of bad they charge
60 bucks for this game
got to keep it real man
goalie let me go could you help me with
oh
she wants he wants to to help the
dashing feature
that's how you do it
that's how you do it
[Music]
oh my gosh
maybe i have to look for zelda yeah it
looks like
a zelda game that's not a bad thing
though like why do people think that
games have to like be dramatically
different
i would never understand that come here
i wonder if i can feed you to my animal
he's probably hungry
we're gonna try
i don't know what you want
the control is a little weird i'm gonna
be real with you guys the controls are
definitely weird
oh my god man
so i found one thing just to not
find another
there was nothing in there
[Music]
just because i'm old and have played
them all i'm just grumpy
yeah i get it man i get it
[Music]
i've beat all the zeldas at least five
to six times
this is the only zelda i've only beat
one time
i've only beat this one time
now i don't know how you have to go
to the weapon place on the right of the
academy and train and get the sword
got to be prepared i suppose
[Music]
appreciate luis for that input man
i'm sure the people didn't want to see
me just run around
to the right
oh that's the restroom
[Music]
the right of the academy is probably to
the actual right
i kind of i'm kind of curious
how the combat's gonna be that they've
modified it a little bit
[Music]
the sparring hall
oh god
[Music]
it's eleanor you still want to get the
sword practice even though today's the
wing i'm impressed the sword is in the
back room go and get it i'm gonna go get
the sword
oh i love that sound man
the practice sword
[Music]
hold up
[Music]
i got it
appreciate that luis man appreciate that
[Music]
oh oh
yeah hold up how do you thrust
move
[Music]
make your sword sharply forward if you
want to get
more about that so like maybe
like run i don't know i'll do that one
last
[Music]
oh my god man this is so
i hate this battle system man
[Music]
i'm taking your sword i'm leaving oh you
won't let me leave
[Music]
what your left is missing but what's
that conception
all right good they're going i should
have read that i don't know why i didn't
read that
all right so you let me take the sword
all right good good good
now we use this to cut the the branch
man
use this to cut the branch
oh my god
gotta keep going a little bit more to
the left
[Music]
press right on the analog stick oh okay
thank you man
it is better than the motion control
that i had on the wii
but i i would have preferred them to to
just
build the game again they probably
probably could have made it look way
better and they could have fixed the
combat system
and it could have justified the 60
dollar price tag
but you know it is what it is
oh god
oh my god
there you go the
waterfall cave
oh get dealt with
oh i'm tired
god i didn't have the pity one man
the combat's horrible man
oh my god
the combat is so bad
oh my gosh this is gonna be rough man
i'm not gonna lie to you it's gonna be
rough
get it i guess the thrust would be the
best ability to use
oh my god
ah such a
horrible combat system
what is that you got a jelly blob i
remember those now
[Music]
i never said it was the greatest zelda
you're mistaking me for king
king said it was the greatest zelda
i don't know if he's ever came out and
said it's the greatest zelda
that might be i might be putting words
in his mouth saying that
but he definitely thinks highly of this
game
[Music]
oh my god it's horrible it's horrible
how do i climb there we go
get that money
i have no clue who's who's on the iop
account
i assume that's king
i don't know man i don't remember him
ever saying it's the greatest
i just remember him saying that it's not
a horrible
saying that's not a horrible zelda
because i always say this is like
the worst 3d zelda that's ever been made
i remember king
saying that it's not the worst 3ds i've
ever made that it's a good game i don't
even remember him
blatantly coming out and saying that
it's the best zelda game ever made
and i will you know i will defend him on
that one
are you gone searching for your bird
around the waterfall and i thought i'd
fly around
and help you look how's your going any
sign of loftwing
oh no it's not lou uh it's not lost hope
yet there's a head
up the goose and his gang are always
hanging around maybe you will find
something there
oh so they got my stuff man
who's this who's calling for me oh look
amiibo i got distracted for a moment
let's go
oh here we go look there he is
[Music]
no doubt about it that's your loft wing
let's let's break him out
it's too it's to your own i suppose man
oh my god
[Applause]
are you gonna let me hit
open up
hold up okay
okay okay okay
okay
got it
you are right there uh this this did
lead to a lot of the stuff in breath of
the wild like
the uh the glider system and the um
[Music]
what is that the glider system the
stanima definitely came from this 100
[Music]
but in my opinion king i think breath of
the wild's
the wrong direction we need to go for
zelda that's just my thing
[Music]
you should fly to the ceremony this is
really going to teach me how to fly
before you go i i have to ask you
something i heard this voice a few
moments ago did you hear it too
it's been hopping a lot lately it's a
strange feeling almost like someone is
calling out to me
have you ever wondered what's the
breadth of what's beneath the clouds
some say that it's empty bar in place or
even that there's nothing at all down
there and i just
have this feeling that they're wrong
all right let's talk about how crazy
the concept of this game is they got
birds
and they're not looking themselves i
don't know
that just seems weird to me some fathers
o
techs talk about some place uh about a
place called the surface the old tales
described a whole world
under there and there's more voss to the
star
uh star skyloft the thing is no one has
ever been down there
and there is to see it and our s and our
loft wings won't fly through the clouds
bear
okay there we go attic talking too much
before adding be reading okay now i know
why
the loft wings they won't fly through
the clouds
but i can't help imagine the wild thing
that might be waiting below
someday i want to see for myself just
jump off you'll find out
but just jump off
just leap off and press down don't worry
about falling your bird will catch up to
you
for sure this time
[Music]
flying
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i always liked the concept with the
birds in sky sword i did always like
that
[Music]
let's run your run through the bases
just to make sure he's not hurt
you can fly your burden in your house
when it's headed upwards and slowly lose
speed
when you're when you want to speed up
direct your bird
to gain after then
steerson
[Music]
there we go there we go
[Music]
let's go down
yeah they definitely put a lot of faith
in these birds
charge x slow down
steal your bird okay
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
but you're looks like he's flying great
my father and the others are probably
worried about your birth
let's give them the good news avatar
vibes which you oh yeah avatar that's
probably
how the avatar game is going to play i
don't know
your life really is amazing especially
considering everything that the poor
guy's been through this morning
i'm going to fly back and tell father
what happened
[Music]
what if it's a me oh amiibo word around
the plaza you found that dumb bird of
yours
well that's just great because you and i
because you and your dumb bird can't
tell
time all that practical loop and the
guys did were for nothing now i'm all
stiff
i've been waiting forever for the for
the race to start now they delayed for
you i don't get it the big
flakes get special treatment
[Music]
you're almost a man and yet you still
can't seem to go anywhere without zelda
oh he's talking a lot of smack man
say we rely too much on zelda
uh
[Music]
don't think we haven't noticed the smoke
looks oh zelda and i are
our best friends we go everywhere
together uh
you think you're pretty sad don't you
well don't you i don't like this dude
man i don't like this dude
i hope he becomes a bad guy so i can
hurt him i can't remember if he does or
not
i don't think he does i can't remember
he might chris has been going on forever
how about
he's going to be one of he's going to be
the one with zelda
he's really got his pampers in a rough
about her
[Music]
dtt that dude looks weird the dude on
the left
i hate to break it to you but today's
the day i bust up with this adorable
little fantasy land you're living in
that is playing the role that god has
said today settlement i'm going to be
the one to claim
that cell cloth
when i heard she made it herself no way
was i gonna let scar just come like uh
as
a scarve clown snatch that prize from me
oh yes that scale clause zelda's club
will be mine
oh man i bet she was thinking about me
when she snitched when she stitched it
i could see it first i win the big race
and then zelda and i finish december
together in the statue
just the two of us i'll it'll be our
special moment together nobody's
stopping me and zelda from having our
moment
and it's so real i can i can see it this
dude's a weird man
oh yeah
[Music]
behind you right behind you it's zelda
okay to explain just what you meant by
our special moment alone
yo she is a very confrontational
zelda she'd be right up in there ask you
what you mean
[Music]
nothing really just i know you know what
i was just telling my buddy how glad i
was you found that red bird of his
boy am i looking forward to this fair
race anyhow
later zelda look for me during the race
i'll be the one pulling
off all the dangerous moves
i don't like this dude i don't like this
dude at all
hey goose wait off
did you know that guy at fairface yeah
the chances that happening or just
are just about less than zero either way
don't let these fools get you down
el amigo get out there and fly the best
you can i know you've got what it
i know you got these guys beat and deep
down i think you do too
obviously
me you can win this
oh here we go man about the race that
looks like the race time
el amivo's a amigo is about to win this
let me bow
me bow
oh you guys think i will win this you
guys think i'm gonna win this
i hope i can win this
hey
uh
your attention please at last we are
ready to begin the wing ceremony
i was going to worry about we have to
proceed without el amigo but luckily
there is no longer a concern
i have attached a small statue to this
bird and
i will release to i i will then release
to the skies on my signal dash from the
starting line
and dive up to the ledge once you are in
the air mount your
your uh lofty
remember to call your bird i'm just not
gonna call my bird i'm just gonna die
whoever catches the statue and claims
the statue will be the year's champion
uh yeah we're good we're good
pretty simple it's like um that thing
from
the thing from uh harry potter
what uh when they play that broom game
that
they have to get that little thing that
flies as you know
today's champion will graduate to the
next class bringing him one closer to
knighthood
he will also receive a gift from the
young woman chose to play the role of
the goddess in this year's ritual
today is this special day for many
reasons but it is also the 25th
anniversary of
fine institution to submit education
today's champion also receive his
goddess
high upon the statue of the statue of
goddess
i hear the young woman's performing the
role of the goddess here has crafted the
gift herself
as you all know the role of the goddess
this year will be performed by
zelda the lovely zelda
[Music]
let's see your finest flying out there
show me just how hard you've been
practicing
also also want to see a good cleave
anyone
caught in a frame with other writers
will answer to me
that goes double for you bruce
all right gentlemen let's let's do this
let's do this for those of you that
don't know this is the very beginning
of the zelda franchise
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
it should give me a little more time
[Music]
oh oh
oh
[Music]
oh what happened
[Music]
oh my god man
[Music]
i need a way for those though
[Music]
come on
come on all three
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh my god why'd you get in my way like
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop flying
don't you know this is my day to get all
the glory is too about to do some real
crazy yep i knew it yeah you heard him
let's
wow i hate people
they throwing eggs at me
see if i can get above them
oh my that was right there
[Music]
come on all three
oh they're throwing these eggs at me man
oh there we go there we go you got the
bird i
did it victory
[Music]
oh she's flying her bird oh no she's not
notice how my birds got tired just from
catching something
what's up fun speculation
don't worry i'm fine great fly elemental
congratulations
now we're better off with and i would
better get off with the ceremony
homeboy gonna be really disappointed he
lost that
happy the birds that you grabbed from
the race i must offer to the goddess
oh here we go
[Music]
i have a feeling something crazy is
about to happen man
i know that she gets took i just can't
remember how
oh yeah for that special the the wii i
don't know if you have to do it on this
one
great goddess guiding light and
protector grant us the blessing and
mercy as i act in the steed during the
ceremony
[Music]
according to the old wide ways i now
believe the blessing of the goddess
among you
[Music]
this is the goddess drift down that's
the little thing that
you fly with
[Music]
that's that also went to uh to breath of
the wild
quick goofing this is supposed to be a
sacred ritual remember
you know they say the goddess gave this
to their chosen hero a long time ago
of course the one holding it isn't the
same one i've been
working hard to finish making this the
the cell cloth in time to give it
today's champion
i'm really glad i got to give it to you
elemental make sure you take good care
of it okay
thanks for making it up here to do this
with me today like you promised
now we really should finish up this
ritual
you do know what happens at the end
right
sort of t i'm glad you're so well
born on the subject
you have to jump off the statue
they made that mad sexual for no reason
look down and see that big
round design on the courtyard to finish
where you need to drop down right
in the center of it first sleep off
right before you hit the ground first to
open yourself cloth
and now i'll brave you if you're really
fearless you wait until the last second
to
we're gonna wait to the oh again with
her pushing me
uh
that was perfect you're amazing al amigo
[Music]
that is one crazy looking bird
you know what we were seeing as you you
won today
and with the wings being so nice
[Music]
you think maybe you'd like to you know
go around the clouds together
[Music]
red blue isn't that so cliche man
the red the blue bird
[Music]
today was amazing watching you win the
race and performing there which are
together i've always remembered this
what is she talking about she acted like
she about to die
it really was wonderful
[Music]
you know elevo
[Music]
there's something i've been meaning to
talk to you about
oh here we go
what is this
is what anthony what you talking about
what's going on
[Music]
oh she gone
el amivo
it's the goddess i'm waiting for you
the time has come for you to awaken you
are virtual to a mission of great
importance
i would say is she going to die
and i don't i don't remember the story i
don't i doubt she's dead
oh there's the big black thing
[Music]
oh you're awake oh
he looks so weird
when your locked one carried you back
you were limped in unconscious i feared
the worst
fortunately you didn't appear to have
any serious injuries for that much
we can be grateful
she was with you was she not
what happened to my daughter she
she got smoked that she shouldn't have
got man i i hate to break it to you
he's explaining it to her notice how
link doesn't talk but he's talking there
a black tornado you say that was no
ordinary tomato
[Music]
no that wasn't a dream he got uh the
bird caught him he got
hit unconscious because of the the storm
you better just not push yourself you're
still recovering tell me when you saw
zelda today did anything
about her seem off
[Music]
i see she was talking about the surface
then and then having a dream about a
great mission how interesting
i'm sorry i was lost in there in thought
there for a moment it's very strange but
i doubt there's much of a connection
between those things
i'm concerned for zoda but so long but
so long as she's with
her uh her loft wing i'm sure she'll be
fine
either way daybreak he has yet to arrive
it would be very difficult to spot one
girl in her
bird in the dark of night it'd also be
very dangerous
rest now el amibo zelda's going to be
fine she's out
there alive i know it
if anything links should be happy that
chick's gone she was one of the most
hating people in this game
oh
let's open the door man
oh there's the goddess
[Music]
where are you going come back here
[Music]
get her get her
get her gotta catch her
don't let her run get her
[Music]
is that thing i threw off the the map at
the beginning of the stream
oh that kind of scared me oh my god
where'd it go
i don't like the motion controls man i
really don't
i'm i'm i'm gonna stick to it because i
promised i would
but this motion control stuff it's
horrible
like it it really is it's horrible
you need to stop being so demonic
[Music]
[Music]
i gotta grab that thing
what the hell is this thing's problem
[Music]
you missed me with that
[Music]
thing is demonic little dog or cat or
[Music]
something
oh i i completely agree with you this
game should not be 60 dollars
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god
i assume i go up here and climb
[Music]
climb
[Music]
you got this man this zod is stiff
yeah it's it's it's the combat man
it really is bad like it
jiggle the sticks i'm gonna i'm gonna
learn them i'm gonna learn them
i don't know if i'll do another live
stream of this i'll probably upload
individual videos after this live stream
probably like do like every when you
guys watch like
just regular content in terms of like
people playing games on youtube
how long is a distance it's like you
feel
is a distant like a length of a video
that's not
too long or not too short is it like 10
to 20 minutes long or is it like 30
minutes long you guys like
content on youtube
oh
[Music]
[Music]
by my creator i have been waiting for
you you will pay in the role of a great
destiny
according to your social customs i
prefer
i should provide you with my personal
designation
fi is the name i was given
i was created for a single purpose long
before the recorded memory of your
people
i must age you to fulfill the great
destiny that is your
carry your burden of caring
come el amivo you must take up the sword
as the one
chosen by my creator it is your destiny
[Music]
the strange dream troubling your sleep
my sudden appearance
uncertainty surrounding the faith of one
you hold dear
under the circus that's only illogical
that you would exhibit some preparation
to minimize your uncertainty allow me to
share some information
my projections indicate that this is the
information has high
probability of altering your current
emotional
state
the one you see the one you seek
honorably zelda is still alive
and the spirit maiden the one you call
zelda is another
chosen one faded to be part of the same
great mission
[Music]
if they get good or for insurance
i don't have to look into it i'm
thinking maybe 20
20 to 30 minutes
that information intrigue you are you
ready to accept this sword
[Music]
it seems that the further persistence
measures will not be required
in the name of my creator draw the sword
and rise it to skyward
this is that like rise bold stuff that
they like doing
examine ready stance
remove
[Music]
rise
[Music]
you got the goddess or the mystery the
mysterious sword is bathed in divine
light
[Music]
recognition complete master of my master
got the sword el amigo
i've had my suspicion but so now i
wasn't sure yeah here we are in the
chamber
of the sword the very place where it was
foretold the
uh the youth of legends would one day
appear
[Music]
it is said that the this place was left
to our people by the goddess herself the
very knowledge of the room's existence
is passed down
to a select few in the generation among
with a handful of words
when the light of the goddess sword
shines bright the great apocalypse will
wake from its long slumber
do not fear for it is a youth guided by
the hand shall reveal
himself in a place most sacred i'm
assuming this is the place that's more
sacred
it started days ago the sword that i've
kept secret all these years it began to
give off a faint
otherworld light
at first i was sure i i i was
at first i was sure i was seeing things
here among
here along with the sword there was
simply no other explanation
i never dreamed of prophecy a legend
would come to in my
pa in my past in my lifetime
the words i have sworn to keep secret
are coming true before my eyes
the youth will be guided by one born of
blade
uh okay hold up the youth will be guided
by
one born of the blade one who is also
youthful and like
likeness yet wise with knowledge
immersively
and yes the oral tradition one of the
least mitch
information transmission it appears that
the critical sections of the passage
have been lost over
the generation so i'm assuming she's
taking the place
of the fairy you know that's that's
what's happening here in case
you guys don't know because in all the
other zones there's been like a there's
been a fairy with you
i can't remember if there was a breath
of the wild i'll probably look that up
later
if you guys remember if uh the fairy was
in the breath of the wild because
in in the first one was navi
i don't remember what it was in majora's
mask
but in ocarina of time it was navi in
majora's mask there was the twin fairies
and the and one of them was with you and
the other ones were skull kitten
the youth was drawn forth the guiding
shorts shall be known as the goddesses
chosen here and
uh it is who possesses an unbreakable
spirit he shall be burdened with the
task
of abolishing the shadow of apocalypse
from the land such
in his destiny with the spirit of the
blade at his side he shall soar over the
clouds
and plummets below and unite with the
great
maiden shall uh and reunite with the
great maiden shall
bring forth the piercing light that will
resurrect the land
summer father's old text talks about a
place called the surface
the hotel described a whole world below
far
more vast than skyloft
master you must embrace on a great
journey beneath the clouds in the vast
realm of the surface
it is only through this journey that you
can fulfill the mission set forth by my
creator
the goddess it is also the only method
available for you to reunite with the
spirit maiden honorable zelda
there is no easy task alameda the world
below is a forsaken place
and to reach it you must pierce the
cloud barrier below
in a living memory no one has ever done
this that
the the sword is going to be where you
will you pierce the uh the veil with
this table will illuminate a path
through the clouds to the land below
take it and place it within the altar
behind me
you got the embro tablet the weathered
surface
of the heavy stone tablet
telling yeah there you go man there you
go i appreciate the uh
the reminder i couldn't remember what
their names was because i remember the
black fairy
turned good at the end it might have
been purple purple black one or the
other
master the first thing you must do is
hit the crest sitting in this broom with
the skyward strike
those blasts are formed pure energy
charge your blade when you lift it
inside once you
swing your shoulders in a powerful sky
with strike okay
[Music]
i like that that's cool okay
[Music]
there we go that's how we charge things
around here
it's a nice little
it's going to reveal purple yeah
[Music]
and that's going to reveal the first
temple
[Music]
okay
until now a cloud bearer created by the
goddess has separated the world you know
from the other one below
the tab will be placed in the other has
opened a small rift in the bear you can
use it to travel through the clouds to
the realm below
i have recognized you as my master and
so my duty to follow you wherever you
may go
i arrest him with your sword and we'll
accompany you in your travels press
through somewhere wherever you go
one good thing about this is i haven't
played this in so long
and and you know i was so much younger
when i played this that
damn i was what i can't even
tell you how old i was uh 10 years ago
no 11 years ago this came out
so i was 16. i don't remember a lot
about the story
and i only played it once see like a lot
of the other zelda games i played
multiple times like multiple multiple
times this is
the only zelda game i only played once
but whatever it turns out to be it seems
that both you and zelda have big roles
to play in the destiny of the land
and you think it is what you said true
fee
fee fi
says his true zelda is alive alive and
no doubt coming to the terms of whatever
it is that the goddess has in store for
her
should you heal the call of destiny i
don't know what dangers you might
have to face el amibo especially down
there but if you decided to brave the
unknown please find my daughter and
bring her back to me
[Music]
okay defies explanation uh we're good
it has been a long night for us both
hasn't it you have a great before even
if those
in those clothes don't look up to the
task the uniform you receive for the
winning the race should be ready by now
the studio that will provide much more
stable for a longer you better change
before you go
that's going to be the green tunic my
friends the green tunic
told you
the green form is what our knights will
be wearing this year to be honest i've
i've had my doubts about the color but
oddly enough seeing you wear this
uniform i can't imagine a more fitting
color for you as as though you were born
to wear it
take care of your journey and be sure to
stop by some of the shops at the visit
here in the town equip yourself properly
for the trials av you will return to
your course and see if you can get more
useful information
from the ancient text you are always
welcome to stop by if you have questions
you insiders should be in my prayers may
the goddess watch over and guide both of
you
[Music]
veg
veg the green room looks so
adventurous you should look like a night
now
the headmaster said you're heading out
you're really something else i could
imagine
doing myself what you've already did i i
put a lot of work into making this you
should take it with you
you got the adventurer proud you can
store all such beautiful information
youthful items in this pouch piece of
gear
[Music]
it's an adventure pouch it's for
adventures it's neat because you can fit
four things in that you'll need on your
big adventure
you can buy all kinds of stuff for the
bizarre and then you can put in this
pouch you should
take a look you could put buy some
potions and a shield they'll fit in the
pouch and they'll
might come in handy on the adventure
find zelda for us at least everyone
likes zelda
it's nice that everyone likes zelda
she could be hated could be the worst
case scenario no one likes zelda
now i look like leak man i look like
link
master i have an update regarding the
stone tablet and the resulting columns
created the column of the light has
appeared to
stop for location and signs that it has
created an opening
in the crown that to the land before i
must use caution is that descending to
the surface armed only with a sword
result in a decreased probability of
survival if you have not already done so
i advise you to purchase a shield
and a potion in preparation for your
journey so i guess they're gonna make us
get the shield man they're gonna make us
you guys know how i am about shields
it shouldn't need a shield to win man
i shouldn't need it
but they're gonna make us wear a shield
[Music]
i assume this is it if i remember i
think this is it
yeah i i knew
i don't care what you have to say i'm
looking for a potion and shield
you look like a good place to buy
potions
oh she gave me an empty bottle for free
for those of you that play zelda
that's a nice gift man that's a nice
game if you've always put in your
adventures press r to take a look
point where you can't fit any more stuff
in your patch because we can always drop
items
all right so
[Music]
all right let's order before we do
anything let's see what these
other ones are that's the stanima yeah
[Music]
magic i assume oh
yeah magic
hold up what did she say i need i need
to read that
let me read
[Music]
this mystery election is known as a
religion potion simply
pour it on a broken shield it moments
the show will be as good as new
oh that's interesting yeah let's buy
that
i feel like i might need that let's buy
that i feel like my shield
is gonna be more important than keeping
my help
who's got a shield
[Music]
oh you have a shield
i bet it costs a lot of money too
50 rubies we got it we got the money man
because always right yeah yeah
hold up
can't tell you unless you have a bomb
bag can you sell me these
man you useless
all right how do i
[Music]
hold up
forget it
that was uh that was an interesting term
of events
can i open this please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh god come back
[Applause]
we going man we in it
[Music]
we going to the world below guys we
doing this
i'm surprised more people don't try to
go down there considering they've never
seen a hole in the veil
is he just gonna hit it is he not oh
okay
[Music]
by my calculations you are currently
positioned in a location known as the
sealed
garden ground still grounds
oh i think this i remember this place
vaguely i remember this place vaguely
[Music]
the sealed grounds
please proceed with caution master
oh god okay
okay here hold this hold this
oh you want more you want more here you
go
oh another one third round's a charm
oh
here hold this
you go
oh yeah that's right let's go let's go
buddy
yeah i don't want no smoke with you guys
i think i have to cut cut the thing off
oh my god
oh my god these these controls
[Music]
hey
these controllers are pretty hardcore
man
not gonna lie i'm not filling the
controls
hmm lee's got a crazy headache right now
[Music]
i remember that black blob like fighting
it
and i think like you knock stuff off of
it or something like that i can't
remember exactly
everything i want to say i fought it in
this area that we're in now
or in a cave i don't remember though i
don't remember
we can always just jump down there and
seize out link
what's the worst that can happen
[Music]
oh my god dude
oh it's rough man
all right i'm gonna have to learn how to
use this a little bit better
young one shout out to this with the sky
rise is sort of the goddess towards the
anger that we are unleashing its power
sure
seems like a good idea let's do it
[Music]
let's unleash the dark one's power man
so nothing happened just wasted a bunch
of time
wasted everyone's time sorry folks
wasted all everyone's time
[Music]
it's a change in this strike that was
triggered in the area that's triggered
by this lord i have also detected an
order that correlates closely to
yourself clock
i suppress that this order belongs to
zelda i can lead you to the direction of
this
please
[Music]
what's going on
i remember this thing now
let's go up
go more up
oh something's open there
[Music]
all right so we got it open
we're getting somewhere man we getting
somewhere
probably gonna end the stream here soon
but i want to check around here real
quick
[Music]
oh yeah i'm ending the stream i'll talk
to you guys later i need to get
something to eat
something to drink i'm i'm tired i
appreciate everyone coming by man
i'll continue these i don't know if it's
going to be live or just individual
videos but
you guys have a good day